stop trying so hard to be someone you're
not don't let anybody else try to bring
you down or make you second-guess
yourself there is not one person on the
face of the planet who can replace you
in honor of International Women's Day
YouTube launched the hashtag dear me
campaign where female youtubers made
videos giving their younger selves
advice wait they went back in time to
give their videos to younger versions of
themselves no that's impossible oh right
yeah yeah of course they just sent
videos back in time I'm Jamie putito and
I'm about to show you the best deer meat
clips on youtube welcome to hashtag news
we have the top female YouTube
contributors posted videos that will
undoubtedly be wonderful learning
experiences for their younger viewers
Lilly reminding us that being normal
isn't important but being yourself is if
I could go back I'd say embrace all
those differences and I think as as you
grow you realize that those differences
make people awesome stop worrying about
being normal Lacey are you making us all
feel better about our insecurities girls
feel so much pressure related to their
looks and every teenage girl that you
know right now is going through the same
thing that you are the pressure to
measure up but take it from me the old
are you but you are good enough you
always have been and there's so much in
store for you in the future Rebecca
Black yeah that Rebecca Black but you
know let's just pretend it's not telling
us that we shouldn't sweat the small
stuff first things first stop being
somewhere in yourself that one bad hair
day or failed test isn't going to matter
in a week or a month or even years the
girls that turned on you or the
rejection you're pasting from that one
boy will be soon forgotten and it's for
the best if you're looking for other
great dear me videos youtube release
this highlight okay dear Lindsay dear
lily beard bunny from long long ago did
me hey I'm a female youtuber I should
give this a try dear me just be yourself
don't let what other people say get you
down also when you go to prom with Kyle
and senior year try your best to hold in
that fart that's going to walk or it's a
condition i think the lesson we can all
learn from these videos is that the
difficult times will pass and even if
you don't think so now your life can
turn out really great and that's it for
hashtag news thank you so much for
watching this video and go ahead and
subscribe if you loved it and you want
to see more videos that i love doing for
you check out our dear me article on new
media rockstars calm for more coverage
and check out the links in the
description for those full dear me
videos
guys